gentlemen it's a rare honor to have you
both here ah thank you Conan in the same
room I'll tell you one thing it's rare
to be here it is I left out the word
honor but
that's just an oversight just before we
started recording
um Marty who
you verbally assaulted me no no no no I
I said it with love that to me when I
see you you look like someone
freeze-dried Prince Harry that's all I
said
I uh it's um you know my staff looks
forward to any time that Marty pardon me
I have a staff wow
it's very lucrative it gets smaller
every year yeah but um no fans of my
show and yes there are fans of the work
that I've done in the past let's not
have any mock surprise about that but
they um they have put together a uh
mashup of uh of Marty coming on the show
and ripping me apart
uh and it is wildly popular oh really oh
yes it is it is wildly popular and it
Delights uh my writers to the point
where the last time when we were
wrapping up the Late Night show a epic
28 year run thank you uh I'm driving to
uh one of the last episodes that Marty's
gonna do uh and he did an extremely
funny bid on it and I'm driving to the
theater and I looked down and I realized
I'm doing something I rarely do which is
wear shorts
[Laughter]
immediately I thought I'm driving
towards the Largo theater and I thought
Marty who's on today Marty's on today
and I knew that he would destroy me and
sure enough you come in and hello hello
everybody and then I see those two eyes
Dart over and they see my freckled legs
there
and it began and it began and it was it
was quite a sun it was absolutely a
terrifying
sight and you couldn't because normally
you can't see where the stilts are
attached you could that day
the shorts revealed way too much oh and
they were short shorts
1970s yeah Joey Heatherton
like you were entertaining the troops
but uh the writers were so so happy and
then of course your the line that just
you said it on late night and it uh it's
lived forever which is well you'll do it
better than I but it was Conan uh
whatever you're doing to your face I say
20 more and then stop
which is
mean in nine years it's a love letter
I love it's also done with care yes
you're worried about me yeah a little
more about 20 more now I feel like I
have to put you down and I've got
nothing no no you don't you don't
because you're Steve oh help
line
uh well I don't want to embarrass either
of you so I won't mention that uh you
are just two of my uh Absolute Comedy
Heroes I'm sure you hear that kind of
thing all the time and it bores you but
one of the pleasures of my life and I'm
not kidding was when you asked me to do
a cameo in your show your live show at
Caesar's Palace in Las Vegas
and I I was outside my body getting to
be be on stage with you guys it made me
so happy so legitimately sincerely happy
you kill I remember you did Kill I mean
you
we learned a lesson because you showed
up with writers one writer I can't
afford two I showed up with my well
you're a writer yeah oh that's true yeah
that's true well I suppose I am
um no I I end uh Matt he's Matt O'Brien
no relation but I only hire O'Brien's
and uh he um idolizes you both as well
and he was just in heaven and then there
was but I thought yeah come along with
me and and help me tweak a few things
since I really wanted it to be
better than what I could it was it was
inspiring and we've had people show up
with with nothing no writers and they
did way better by the way
and then I heard you guys later bumped
into Letterman and he was like Conan
brought a writer no no because Dave did
it as well right yeah what was the line
you were sitting off stage with Dave and
he looked
what was it you were sitting off stage
waiting for me to come on they look kind
of morose this sounds like Dave so far
they edit by the way he had okay no no
no no he didn't oh not at all no an
editor costs money as well everything is
in uh no but
um it was fantastic it was uh but I
remember you were saying that Dave was
sort of he had been off the air for just
a little bit and then of course he
always does the thing where he's
horrified that he if I go on stage it'll
just be awful yeah and I'm like you're
David Letterman what are you you know
but he's done it and of course the place
goes nuts yes and then and then
afterwards he still has a negative
feeling about it even though he's killed
yeah he but he had only been off a few
I think this was like in June and he'd
left six weeks before right exactly
exactly but he is his personality is
always you know he came by and which
meant a lot to me did a cameo on late
night which was his old studio and he
came by and of course his attitude was
well they're just gonna hate me well
there's a you know there's a
there's an event how will they know who
I am will you say my name before I come
out there's a self-defense mechanism in
being overly paranoid and then when you
get a little cheer when you come out and
you go oh I was wrong yes yes I'm
familiar with it with Marty yeah I think
with me yes I think and it would I think
it's kept me out of the big money not
having that attitude I'm just kind of
going oh you don't like me well you know
I don't like you either but good night
yeah it is a little he does have that
attitude I'm this insecure shaking one
and he says I don't give a right
they're going to love me well if they
don't guess what if I had dinner with
them I'd be bored that's all exactly oh
yeah well often that was your opening
line though it was and I didn't know why
I didn't play
who are you people no one's bathed
Obviously good night
where's my big money why didn't I get
the big money why don't they like me
they don't ever me again I was um so I
got to see your show uh and I was so
impressed with how you guys worked it
out and even though you both knew the
show so well you had a rehearsal and you
were still
uh working so hard to make sure that it
went perfectly at rehearsal and I
thought this is there are no accidents
like people that are good in my opinion
there yes there is talented but there
was talent but then there's just this
just mad desire to get it perfectly
right and it never goes away well I
always think that that by the way I'm
here too go ahead oh
did you just sneak into this chair
no but I'm always amazed I feel like I
should I start raising my hand
okay well go ahead you say something no
I don't have it I had something I say I
I think we prepare I prepare out of fear
yep and also love because when we get a
new joke I've I'm energized the whole
show I cannot it's true wait to get to
this joke and often they don't work in
fact here's an example because I thought
let me just say when they don't work uh
I am like either on stage or in the
wings I go hysterical yes because he's
been so excited all day about this go
ahead I had a joke the other night I
thought when I introduced Marty I
thought oh this this is really going to
work right and then we're going to
analyze why it didn't work afterwards
yes but I said and this man he's he's
done live television he's been in film
and he's done Broadway and truly he is a
master of the toxic workplace
environment
and it was just sort of like yeah and uh
I realized later it's had too many words
in it yeah you know it needed to be more
of like a casual throwaway in the middle
of our inside toxic you had to have just
read the story about uh that um
no no I don't think everyone is
following you know variety everybody
memorized about a toxic workplace
environment obviously because you've got
nothing yeah remember that part I mean
Conan shorts represent a toxic workplace
absolutely for the crew oh we settled
out of court